Artus: "Voilà, ça c'est Michel"
Fabien:"ça va Mimiche ?"
A: "Le relou"
F:"Michel aussi il fait de la magie, il fait apparaitre de la pisse quand il est heureux"
F:"Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec Artus"
A:"Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec Fabien"
F:" C'est la première fois qu'on me présente, merci
Au début quand j'ai lancé ces vidéos, les potes ils venaient chez moi
et je faisais une vidéo avec eux et maintenant comme ils veulent plus venir
je viens les voir en fait, je frappe et..."
A: "Et puis t'es ponctuel ça j'ai appris ça, ça c'est cool
parce qu'on peut quand même l'annoncer au gens, hein. C'est que t'as fais le tour de Paris pour venir chez moi"
F:"C'est parce que là on est dans quoi, on est dans quel arrondissement ?
A:" On est dans le 6ème"
F:" Et moi je suis dans le 18ème"
A:"C'est pas les plus proches"
F:" Moi je leur dis : me donne pas ton adresse, je suis mentaliste, je vais te retrouver
et j'ai fait 3 fois le tour du 6ème, je me suis retrouvé dans le 18ème
je savais pas du tout ce qu'on allait faire avec Artus aujourd'hui et je me suis dit tiens voilà un mec simple
ça se voit d'ailleurs puisque... un corps svelte"
A:" eh en pleins travaux..."
F:"Et du coup, tu fumes ?"
A:" Nan... C'est pas bien ! Mais oui je fume"
F:" Nan, mais tu fumes des cigarettes électronique avec de la nicotine"
A:" C'est ça"
F:" Et sans électricité parce que tu es contre ça"
F:"euh, tu peux en prendre une, est ce que tu peux l'allumer s'il te plait
A: "Bien sûr"
F: "On va voir là... on va voir là... on va voir là c'est pas mal
F: "Vas y allume allume je t'en prie"
A: " *tousse*
F: " Alala on voit que tu as pas l'habitude
A: " c'est la 1ère"
F: "Tu vois il est 20h
A: "En plus y'a mes parents vont peut être regarder
F: "Il est 20h c'est la 1ère de la journée, tu fumes pas beaucoup non plus
A: "Je fais quoi je la finis?"
F: "Euh non mais on peux parler en même temps"
F:"Tu connais la méthode Coué ou pas?
Pas la méthode Cauet la méthode Coué
A: "Oui"
F: "La méthode d'auto-suggestion"
A: "Se convaincre de quelques choses"
F: " Exactement, alors on va essayer de faire la méthode Coué"
F: "Alors on va plutôt se mettre par là"
F: "Je vais me mettre de ce côté là ça ne te dérange pas."
A: "Pas de soucis"
F:"Je change de place moi"
J'ai mes petites habitudes
tu vas tendre le bras gauche comme ça en essayant  de rester dans le champs.
Ah çà c'est super là on est bien.
et tu vas me passer ta cigarette.
F: moi je fume plus
F: "Donc je prends des gros risques en faisant ça,je fume plus depuis le 13 mars 2014"
A: "Eh bé tu es reparti"
F: " Et tu vas répéter après moi : ça brûle pas ça brûle pas"
A: "ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas "
Les 2: ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas"
F: "mais ça chauffe un peu"
A: "ça chauffe un peu mais ça brûle pas"
F: "Je t'explique pourquoi ça chauffe quand même.
ça chauffe parce que dans ton champs vision périphérique tu vois le point d'impact qui va se faire
A: "D'accord"
F: "Et donc tu anticipes la douleur et la chaleur"
A: "Ok"
F: "Donc on va le refaire "
F: "Je tire pas de latte, hein, c'est important"
A: "Tu l'as fait y'as longtemps ce tour ou pas?"
F: "Olala oui je l'ai pas fait depuis des années ^^"
*Rire*
F: "Bon allez on est reparti"
A: "C'est quoi? Je regardes pas là? je fais quoi là?
F: "Non j'ai caché donc tu ne verra pas de point d'impact.Par contre, ne bouge pas la main ça pourrait être dangereux sinon.
A: "Ouais"
F: "Tu es prêt?"
Les 2: ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas,ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas...
ça brûle ou pas?!, ça brûle pas,
F: "ça brûle pas mais là ça fume un petit peu tu vois."
A: "ça brûle pas"
F: "Et là si j'écrase
F: "ça dit quoi?"
A: "ça brûle pas"
F: "Pour l'instant ça va?"
F: "C'est vrai"
A: "ça brûle pas"
*Rire de Fabien*
F: " ça brûle pas..."
A: " Tu sais avec la larme ça brûle pas, non ça brûle pas"
F: "Ecoute on a bien tout écrasé, tu vas mettre ton autre main comme ça"
F: Et tu places l'ensemble par dessus comme ça"
A: Ok
F: "Et faut pas que tu bouges c'est important"
A: "Ok je ne bouge pas"
F: "tu bouges pas? ok"
F: " Et tu répètes encore ça brûle pas
Les 2: ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas, ça brûle pas"
F: "Voici ce qu'il va se passer"
F: "Artus à 3 et seulement à 3
tu vas écrasé DOUCEMENT ma main contre la tienne
tu vas écrasé doucement ma main contre la tienne
En disant ça n'a jamais brûlé, je n'ai jamais fumé"
A:  "ça n'a jamais brûlé, je n'ai jamais fumé"
F: "Maintenant tu peux ouvrir les mains"
tout doucement
A: "Oh l'enc****"
F: "Et en temps normal on trouve pas de cigarette
ça veut dire que tu N'AS jamais fumé"
A: "D'accord, je peux m'en rallumer une du coup?
parce que j'ai pas..."
F:" Fais voir par terre quand même
tu cherches aussi.OH dis donc!!!
tu regardez un film"
F: "Ah oui c'est vrai, on va le voir toute la vidéo" *rires*
A: "Ah non non non non"
F: "Sur la go pro"
A: "Alors oui c'est les anges de la télé-réalité.C'est Friends strip
Mais c'est parce qu'en fait comme je bossais sur l'ordinateur
j'ai mis ça en fond mais je regardais pas vraiment
Ah non, c'est eux qui partent. Non mais voilà ça m'intéresse pas
A: "C'est Michel qui a la cigarette.Regardez
Hop popopop et là qu'est ce qu'on sort: La cigarette"
*Rire*
A: "ça ça serait balèze"
F: "C'est vrai
c'est vrai.On peux le faire... mais après il souffre"
F: "Merci beaucoup. Alors Artus est en spectacle en ce moment en tournée et toute les semaines à Paris tu fais le volte vanne
A: "Oui"
F: "Que j'avais fait d'ailleurs je vous mettrais un lien dans la description.
il y a toujours la vidéo en ligne?"
A: "il y a toujours la vidéo en ligne"
F: "C'est un concept vraiment drôle puisque on fait chacun notre sketch et après on reprend le sketch de l'autre
A: 'Voilà t'as tout expliqué"
F: "C'est fais au hasard"
A: "Et c'est moi qui t'avais tiré au sort d'ailleurs"
F: "Ah oui c'est vrai c'était drôle"
A:" C'est moi qui avais fait le mentaliste"
F: "C'était tellement drôle"
A: "Ouais mais j'ai pas le même talent mentalisme"
F: "Si, il avais eu une idée tellement ouf en fait que... jamais j'y aurai pensé
mais c'était tellement bien"
A: "de reprendre les mêmes gens?"
F: "Ben oui"
c'est ça il a pris les mêmes gens donc il a redeviné les mêmes choses.
A: "Eh ouais"
F: "C'était une arnaque"
A: "Et oui qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise..
on peut dire que j'écris le nouveau spectacle tout à fait qui va s'appeler
Il était une fois Artus, puisque c'est sur les légendes et les contes
F: "Il m'as fait lire un petit peu les ... euh... le titre en fait"
A: 'Ben le titre parce que pour l'instant j'ai écrit que le titre
F: " Ecoute on a tout dis tu voulais dire un truc en plus ou pas?
A: "Non bisous"
F: "Bisous ça c'est beau
Et quand à nous RDV à demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog
Ciao"